all right so here's a movie you've been
waiting for me to talk about I'm going
to be honest I was just going about my
day and I was like what else comes out
this weekend besides Exorcist bever
totally killer not going to lie it does
not sound like my thing I don't know why
probably because the title is totally
killer there's nothing about that that
screams hey Jeremy you busy this
Thursday we have a film here waiting for
you but it was on Amazon Prime the
effort to watch it was very
minimal so [__] it the fact that I'm
even doing this video probably tells you
the movie is God awful or surprisingly
enjoyable don't you give me that
deductive reasoning like well you don't
have a scotch in your hand so it must
have been surprisingly good I don't
drink in every negative
[Music]
review so totally killer is a
light-hearted kind of com well I mean
it's a comedy yeah but I think it was
trying to be more comedic than it ended
up being because I never had those laugh
out loud moments but I did have Chuckles
a story is back in 1986 there was this
serial killer who killed three girls in
this high school and then disappeared
all these years later one of the
surviving girls from that school has a
daughter of her own that girl gets
blasted back to 1986 correction 1987
whatever so she's privy to some
information which she's going to be like
I'm going to try to stop this killer
sounds like Back to the Future meet SL
reflect but isn't yeah pretty much the
movie stars k shipka who I thought was
great as the lead in the film she gets
blasted back to the 80s so what's the
fun there what's the fun in a time
travel comedy well talking [__] about
the times obviously example she gets a
ride to school from one of the parents
one of the parents being a smoker she
opens the door and the smoke just just
nicotine smoke everywhere two little
kids in the back seat just watching her
go to school just in nicotine smoke it's
going to be an entire generation of kids
are going to be like that did that
happen back then yes and that's probably
the reason I have a Dy C off to this day
sometimes it's [__] talk about the time
sometimes it's just technology they
don't have then the main characters like
oh I didn't even think that they
wouldn't have that like DNA I mean not
to say DNA didn't exist yeah life itself
wasn't around no DNA testing that's what
I mean there was a part of me when the
movie started that was a little
concerned as to whether or not the
movie's going to be unintentionally
campy I'll probably never get the answer
to that question but when you see the
time machine it just looks like yeah
this high school student creates a time
machine 10 years ago on that premise
alone I would have said okay this is
obviously a comedy you're not supposed
to take that too seriously but just this
year we saw a movie where a high school
student made a Quantum device in a
garage that took them to meet Kang so
[__] if I know what you're supposed to
take seriously anymore but the time
machine itself the prop looked like
someone went to a random Spencer's Gift
in a mall in the 9s and grabbed up all
the little lighting things that they
sell there slapped them together in 2023
so yeah it looks like the time machine
prop involved time travel itself to make
point is somewhere between slasher flick
cheese comedy and
lighthearted parental time travel
Adventure the film does find its stride
and I was able to kick my feet up and
enjoy myself in which case [__] I guess
there is logic to the the observation
that no Scotch means I'm not going to
bag on the film and the point is it
doesn't have to I'm going to get you
next time negative review no Scotch
head's going to spin the serial killer
element itself is actually one of the
weak spots of the film first of all the
Killer is called the sweet 16 killer
because he stabs the victim 16 times it
sounds brutal when I'm explaining it for
a YouTube video on screen in execution
it's violent enough but it can lack
variety not a deal breaker but
undeniably part of the fun of a slasher
flick is the varying ways the killer
will dispatch someone here you know well
he's going to stab the person let me
guess 16 times they do their best to
shake it up there is actually a pretty
solid group fight against the killer
that I really like Not only was the
killer mask week it just looks like a
generic purge mask you can get from
Spirit Halloween store right now maybe
it's supposed to be a Max hrum mask
without the sunglasses that would make
more sense for the time this takes place
in but I thought the killer reveal was
weak as well you could have done so much
more given the premise of the film and
just kind of like oh okay I guess the
thing I enjoyed most about it wasn't
even the serial killer backdrop it was
the dynamic between the daughter and her
parents yes it's a premise we've seen
many times in film iconic films even the
movie does at least address the
parallels with Back to the Future in
here on screen I like the take on the
parental dynamic because it is kind of
like Back to the Future but Back to the
Future but what if Lorraine and George
McFly were dicks what if your parents
were the kind of [__] in high school
who would never hang out with you and
you could not hang out with them but you
have to because you have to save them
from a serial killer it's not a
cinematic deconstruction of the slasher
film horror genre per se that we've seen
films effectively be in the past but it
is an enjoyably self-aware time travel
slasher film party movie for when you
and your friends want to lighten the
mood for that Halloween Horror Night
movie binge with some drinks yeah now
it's a party are so totally killer have
you seen it what did you think about it
or for your Halloween binge what's a
Halloween movie that's more fun than
scary whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
more
[Music]